Comcast competitive acapella group sings
the Universal Studios theme during their
set please don't stop the please no stop
the white guys singing Rihanna
wait two dudes have microphones and the
rest are being picked up by stage mics
not even visible in the shot
if acapella is your co-pilot then what
is God doing beatboxing it was the
actual pilot
you I'm guessing this plane crash is
pretty often movie thinks if it puts
respected comic actors in this I'll
forget I'm watching a movie clearly
riding the coattails of Glee or ripping
it off whatever you prefer
you're unreliable and your breath smells
like a group leader takes acapella true
leader competition dance-offs way too
seriously cliche flight attendant
outfits might increase the power of
boners but won't help your acapella
group competition final score is it me
or do we just take a left turn in a
Snoozeville it is not you I sign and it
opened up my eyes I saw sir a female
acapella group actually thought that
singing Ace of Base would not end in at
least one of their singers vomiting on
stage also in 2013 Hollywood still think
someone grossly puking equals comedy and
Hollywood has never been more wrong this
isn't gross Jesus I need a minute and
that's how the movie warms you up ladies
and gentlemen it just projectile vomited
bean dip all over your face so take that
so far John Michael Higgins and
Elizabeth Banks have stolen this movie
from the main characters but we won't
get to see them again for a long time DJ
software action scene gets us up close
and personal with the magic of laptop
track mixing next up 10-minute
tour-de-force
unbroken shot of keyboard strokes during
a session of adobe premiere also you
know she's unique because her
fingernails are black track she's
working on has a sample of young MCS
bust a move which means she's trying to
become successful using other people and
making her own thing out of it now I
know nobody else would do such a thing
so this character has already pissed me
off beyond belief and I'm really angry
about it although character is Anna
Kendrick and I just can't stay mad at
her for long no matter what I do so sin
on her for making me like her so much
well backseat rocking out to Kansas and
your official vu
rapist whoa whoa light-hearted movie
just through a rape whistle into the mix
also are their unofficial like knock off
bu rape whistles this kid is way into
Star Wars and that's fine but what the
fire Houdini posters doing next to the
Death Star and ruining an excellent Star
Wars motif for no reason at all that I
can think of I'm going to knock a sin
off Becca cranks up her loud ass mix
right in front of the roommate that
already hates her without using
headphones kind of a dick move Becca
LA and get a job at a record label and
start paying my dues DJing is not a
profession it's a hobby first off I
don't even know why the career-driven
adult Becca hasn't already moved to LA
and skipped the college even if her
professor dad allows her to get an
education for free second off get once
to do something parents don't approve of
cliche I'm going to the activities fair
my super-good friend Kimmy Jen and we're
going to leave you here all alone in the
dorm room with no way of locking it when
you finally decide to leave and Becca's
tracks got stolen probably by that
asshole and step up troublemakers
you gotta love those college campuses
where everyone you need to know is out
on the quad doing the one thing their
characters are known for the size of
Barda so two of last year's national
acapella finalists squads were from this
one tiny college I had to Shin for you
three times it never got in because you
said my boobs look like baloney or black
circular pieces of tape also that's a
valid complaint but that's not a valid
complaint for getting into an acapella
group where you'll be wearing outfits
that will cover your Bologna boobs so
I'm conflicted on the validity of this
complaint while I try to figure out
whether my boner is voluntary I am
confident that we will find eight
superhot girls with bikini-ready bodies
Wow
our success toward their own gender but
what can I say I'm a quarter sexist
myself ironically I get it from my mom's
side Quidditch Club oh yeah DJ's stiff
geez too deaf Jewish people decided to
make a club basically so that Becca
could get excited about joining a DJ
club only to have the rug pulled out
from under there not even at their table
right now so they can drop the bomb on
her own comedy stock I saw you guys
perform in a mall of America like three
years ago Jesus how long is this college
a cappella group in acapella also now
we're supposed to believe that this guy
we met in a Darth Vader cape and with
his side of the room decked out in Star
Wars and Houdini posters is suddenly the
hugest fan of the troublemakers and he
didn't have one poster shirt or any
other kind of memorabilia that suggested
this beforehand you guys go a long way
for comedy and we appreciate that but
still suitable as I dunno
you sang to you I remember because you
were in a taxi actually no she was
standing outside a taxi when you were
shamelessly air-guitar in Kansas more
exciting track mixing Gaga asshole dad
just walks in daughter's dorm room
without getting the go-ahead Becca
unknowingly belts out a great audition
for people who just happened to want her
to join the acapella group and just
happened to be in the bathroom at the
same time cameraman fails at his job
right now scene does not contain a lap
dance you were seeing titanium right you
know David Guetta yeah he's so tough to
stumble across in everyday life if you
sing the same boring girly shit every
year you will blow chunks all over the
place despite being an asshole this
bumper Alan dickhead is right how in the
fuck did the Bellas get into a national
championship singing stuff that the
audience and judges immediately found
boring it was cool there was all pretend
and here's the bad singer montage cliche
it's almost as tired as the woman who
goes on dates with men who are
hilariously unacceptable cliche
dedicated took the time wasn't long and
took called you behind well they all
auditioned in the same key that's
amazing I didn't know we had to prepare
that song oh that's okay
seeing anything you want person
conducting auditions is massively unfair
to the rest of the tryouts because she
saw this chicks boobs in the shower once
why is this dude still here is it
because he's a main character trying to
be the female leads love interest well
back off asshole she's mine The Sopranos
Jessica Mary Elise Lily you know the one
you can't even hear because she's so
quiet for coming and our Altos fat Amy
you know one of the awful singers you
didn't like for comedy do my eyes
deceive me are you a Barden Bella nope
Kristen Stewart played Bella somehow
Anna Kendrick was one of the secondary
characters and Edward Collins obsession
would have made more sense well I can
see how you'd make that mistake ladies
gather around ready for a show yeah
these guys probably aren't popular in
any other circle but in this circle
there's supposedly a really popular
acapella group that wins national
championships and should be swatting
away women in this world left and right
acha party
wait this amphitheater and it's party is
located right outside Benji and Jesse's
dorm room I guess for optimal sadness
does anyone here have anything to
confess it was an accident
you mean boning a troublemaker how do
you accidentally bang someone oops
slick floors fell right onto a penis
there but while we're here also why even
admit it are there further penalties for
lying about it past getting kicked out
of the Bellas this is a list of all of
the songs that we have ever performed
and you will notice that we only do
songs made famous by women because what
didn't work in the past will almost
certainly work this year what are you
doing I'm doing horizontal running and
yet banging a troublemaker is somehow
worse than this behavior I can see your
toner through those jeans that's my dick
damn my whole world just got up there
this is a cute scene but damn how long
have they been working together now
surely a guy as affable as him has been
able to break the ice with the cool DJ
want to be chick before now jaws et The
Breakfast Club Star Wars and rocky I
would have included taxi driver in
Apocalypse Now but I'm only going for
the popular vote here best scored and
soundtracked movies of all time
Wow movie gives the finger to Michel
chiquinho James Horner Hans Zimmer and a
host of amazing composers not to mention
the soundtracks of classic song
compilation movies by folks like Quentin
Tarantino Cameron Crowe and Martin
Scorsese what do you not like movies or
something apparently Beca would be
excellent at cinemasins
which we just might be open to giving
her a job but on the flip side Jessie
would be excellent at criticizing cinema
since what that question people always
ask us both of these characters have
their place in our hearts when Darth
Vader is Luke's father oh right so you
just happened to guess the biggest
cinematic reveal in history Vader and
German means father oh come on
it certainly isn't pronounced like that
and it's not spelled like that either
plus you'd still have to do some decent
sleuthing to figure out that reveal even
if you made the connection so don't give
me that I still love you though
the biggest cinematic reveal in history
you said this line after The Crying Game
The Sixth Sense the usual suspects
fallen The Prestige primal fear and a
host of great cinematic reveals had
already come out oh and your
this riff-off is kind of fun I guess but
they could have explained the rules
beforehand you hear what the rule is
later but it seems like a Greatest Hits
commercial where they play snippets of
song so you'll buy a compilation CD hey
man is that freedom rock well turn it up
man I'm having a good time
I really am but I still feel the need to
remind myself you that I'm watching an
acapella ripoff in an empty swimming
pool at a college for nerds the tough
blow ladies the word you needed to match
was it and you sang its hey man I'm with
you
nitpickers are the best people in the
world of course but that's hardly an
accurate technicality and what a bunch
of bull if you felt so strongly about it
you should have cut her off earlier face
so wait they won I get that they won
this round but they sing like two rounds
what I'm putting ripoff this riff off is
The Breakfast Club 1985 greatest ending
to any movie ever
not damn it you made this movie after
such film endings as The Crying Game The
Sixth Sense the usual suspects Bal dis
song launched simple minds in the US
could have been a Billy Idol song but he
turned it down
yeah because Billy Idol wasn't
successful in the least and could have
really used that Breakfast Club boost
besides do you want Breakfast Club
ending in a Billy Idol song instead of
this one things happen for a reason dude
the white girls back that's super racist
hey just because you wear an outfit like
the one you're warming up in the air
doesn't mean you're getting an Oscar for
this you can't fool the Academy welcome
ladies and gentlemen the acapella
regional championship brought to you by
Apple and the two announcers who will go
on to announce the national championship
but whatever pay no attention to those
name actors we pay too much for all so
is this on TV or the radio at least in
dodgeball they were on the Ocho and it
kind of made sense but this who's
listening to this and who would want
announcers giving play-by-play over the
songs also packed houses
these are niche acts but apparently they
have the pull of Becker 1980s Def
Leppard the one day win a trophy by
making music with their map ritty
progressive and liberally the movie
decides to drown out the lily allen
lyrics with play-by-play which is odd
considering the actual lyrics they
obscure which are so you say it's not
okay to be gay well I think you're just
evil
you're just some racist who can't tie my
laces meaning movie is afraid to be
anti-racist and Pro gay is it
or are those skirts just not working
anymore hey fuck you buddy there's some
pretty damn hot replacement chicks in
this group we're going to split hairs
here do we need a hundred percent
hotness to get down with the skirts hey
I got a new life
I understand tradition but the Bellas
literally perform the same song as last
year and I think that's a party foul
even in acapella circles exactly you ant
advancing to this year's semifinals the
Barden Bellas even though they st.
boring and old songs according to the
acapella announcers hey it's discount
skinny ron jeremy and discount donald
face holy Sh oh just what this movie
needed an acapella fist fight complete
with known comic actors playing second
fiddle cameos it's just like the
anchorman fight only with more copying
hey Hilary Swank from Million Dollar
Baby hey you know you just have to say
hey Million Dollar Baby you don't have
to reference the specific actress well
maybe he does since you've stated so
clearly that you hate movies and don't
watch them maybe it's a reflex on his
part you ever think about that thanks
for bailing me out well I didn't you
call my dad Becca's dad who is angry and
paid the bail decides to sit in the car
to wait for his daughter
so the reveal is more dramatically
devastating I don't need your help
you're not my boyfriend
god I hate it when Anna Kendrick reminds
me of this every day when I break into
her house to do her laundry I did not
have you pegged as an a cappella girl
it's cuz you don't know Becky like I do
is this really a rivalry early on it
looked like Bela kind of like this DJ
dude and I don't blame her he's pretty
dreamy but where the hell does this come
from what a douchey thing to say even
for the guy we want to be with Becca by
the end of the movie that amy is clearly
not unconscious or showing any signs of
needing CPR but because the movie thinks
Cynthia Rose being a lesbian is so
hilarious
they make her do this when any child
knows Amy doesn't need CPR but the true
big-ass burrito at me so why all the
theatrics about getting shot was it all
for the CPR gag please don't tell me
that was all for the CPR gag Jesus this
is the slowest drive to anywhere ever
anything unfortunately this bus
sing-along must compete with almost
famous in which tiny dancer was sung and
when it comes to cinematic sing-along
throwdowns Elton John is going to beat
Miley so up the ante movie running out
of gas on the way to something really
important cliche and let's not forget
this is all because of the hysterics
involving a burrito so this movie is one
part step up one part that reality
competition show pentatonix one and one
part the end of Sister Act two
I got a new life seriously how has the
movie not answered the question about
how this group gets so far in
competitions with their boring ass act
apparently judges visibly show what
pleases and displeases them so you can
change your act in the middle to
accommodate them also this one little
extra flourish is gonna make the judges
find it less boring
get the fuck out of here with a tweak of
course you're here right now I don't
need your help okay
can you back off I just wrote a rant
about how much of an asshole Becca is
but how can I stay mad at her anyway
what an asshole
take a look fellas because I can
honestly say this is the most convenient
bag noticed by a secondary character to
advance the plot in the history of
cinema happy Spring Break thanks indeed
thanks for that unexpected exposition
Camille in it has come to our attention
that you are not in college I'm
speechless
I mean you trust someone and then they
do this to you what I mean of course is
this movie telling us there's actually a
kid out there who loves acapella so much
he would pose as a college student to
enter competitions for it also a movie
gets a convenient out to propel the plot
you know these are all pretty good
movies ET jaws rocky Schindler's List
say anything Animal House and even
Slumdog Millionaire has its charm but
think Scarface is officially the most
overrated movie of all time and with all
the DECA was talking about movies
earlier I find it hard to believe she
got through it just because she's
secretly making up with Jessie behind
his back kind of not the same without
everyone hey we need Becca really
Becca's the one who's been holding this
together the whole time since when what
oh man I just need a hot dog too if
you're a Chicago Blackhawks fan you
extra hate this puke fight ballet scene
Lilly is pretty much doing what the
audience is forced to do right now now
that everyone is kissed and made up they
nailed a song they practice on the first
try which a messed up vocal cords you
could hit the bass notes hahaha I mean I
was already giggling Moody will now turn
into a concert film but is it interested
in letting us see some of the
choreography without massive edits it is
not you don't think that's a problem
it's a problem gone are those Bella
uniforms and this is a whole new look
for them and it is hot hot hot you
clearly didn't like them before because
the new faces on the team so why did it
change an out that's turned you around
on these girls you didn't like to look
at before it's not about the money
after rehearsing a Bruno Mars thing the
night before in the empty swimming pool
the Bella's opted to go with the
completely unrehearsed Jessie J medley
for the competition also I thought they
didn't have much time to get ready for
the Lincoln Center performance but they
somehow worked out three songs and all
their choreography and like a couple
days I guess well you come see about me
damn this girl went a long way to win
the guy but not the competition all
right nerds let's go with suspense Oh
Chloe don't worry it's just God
punishing me because you're a ginger
that's it
I'm freaking out take in the middle of
the credits also that's racist I have
notes what oh my god
hello everybody and welcome this year's
annual Las Vegas international dodgeball
open brought to you exclusively here on
ESPN 8 the Ocho what is it
here's some things started out with no
garlic our pencil thing I've ever been
this excited you're excited feel these
nipples but I am my father's daughter
I always get nervous when you start with
the numbers Carol and then ticket South
gone shining man
she's welcome welcome happy Hunger Games
ah maybe odds be ever in your favor
and he had this rad shopper those are
flames and stuff
oh and he's faced with a skull and it
was on fire on fire yeah like like that
much fire here's a pitch-perfect
drinking game order up some Club W wine
by going to club W comm slash cinemasins
then watch pitch perfect drink a sip of
wine every time the following happens
something racist sexist fat shaming or
otherwise discriminatory a song a
character pukes or Anna Kendrick is
adorable and if you remember any of your
evening be sure to send your memories to
cinemasins at gmail.com because they'll
make one hell of a video since you'll be
crushed
anyway club w comm slash cinemasins is
where you can sign up for monthly whine
to your door delivery service its wine
to your door first bottles free just for
our viewers do you ever just get down on
your knees and thank God that you know
me access to my dementia wine where's
the garden said wine to your door where
as the god of said wine so what are you
waiting for go get your wine on
yeah another one Hanna